c'est l'heure de notre second débat
comme chaque soir vous le savez on
décide de prendre du recul sur
l'actualité on tente de vous donner des
clés de compréhension des mutations de
notre société justement en voilà une de
mutation les crypto monnaie il y a deux
semaines l'un des géants du secteur la
plateforme des changes FTX ça fait
faillite provoquer la la ruine de
milliers d'investisseurs on va y revenir
avec nos experts se poser de la question
de l'avenir de ces crypto monnaie mais
d'abord de la pédagogie on vous explique
comment ça marche le fonctionnement de
ces monnaies virtuelles avec emo Touré
vous ne le voyez pas mais certains
clients de ce bar ont un point commun
original il possède deux portefeuilles
l'un et physiques et l’autre numérique
ils font partie des 4 millions
d'investisseurs français en crypto
monnaie avec la crypto je fais un
financement à la Croix-Rouge voilà
maintenant grâce à la block
chain
la crypto monnaie est un moyen de
paiement utilisable et essentiellement
sur Internet indépendant des réseaux
bancaires est lié à un système de
cryptage leur technologie repose sur la
blockchain une chaîne de blocs au
registre décentralisée du coup j'ai
investi plusieurs milliers d'euros dans
les crypto monnaie mais vraiment pas pas
avec l'angle pas avec l'angle de gagner
de l'argent fondamentalement c'est aussi
plutôt même investir dans une certaine
vision de ce que peut apporter le
numérique le secteur dont la popularité
explose depuis une décennie est encore
fragile dernier exemple en date FTX
deuxième plateforme mondiale d'échange
de crypto actifs a fait faillite le 11
novembre elle emporte dans sa chute des
milliards de fonds appartenant à ses
clients mais pas de quoi décourager les
aficionados
c'est pas un outil d'investissement je
peux dire que dans tout mon entourage il
garde leur portefeuille et ce qui croit
que à horizon 10 ans ça va vraiment
impact tous l'écosystème j'ai perdu un
peu mais j'assume mes pertes welcome une
crypto oui c'est dur 3 milliards de
dollars c'est ce que FTX doit toujours à
ses plus gros créancier pour mieux
encadrer les entreprises du secteur la
France possède une réglementation depuis
2019 les sociétés opérant dans
l'Hexagone doivent s'enregistrer auprès
de l'Autorité des marchés financiers un
cadre précurseur qui a inspiré la
directive européenne Mika mais qui reste
insuffisance selon l'Association pour le
développement des actifs numériques même
si on avait eu Mika aujourd'hui en
Europe on aurait absolument pas empêché
un acteur de faire une fraude tel qu'on
a pu le voir sur FTX on a un enjeu
d'harmonisation à l'international de la
réglementation et aujourd'hui on le voit
en France on a aucune sanction à l'égard
des entreprises qui ne sont pas en
conformité avec nos règles davantage
qu'un sujet de réglementation c'est un
sujet de supervision que pose cette
affaire superviser des réglementations
oui mais avec quelle expertise la
sénatrice centriste Nathalie Goulet
souhaite créer une une commission
d'enquête sénatoriales sur les crypto
actifs sa mission principale dresser un
état des lieux sur les dangers et
l'accessibilité de ces derniers je pense
qu'on a intérêt à se préparer à la fois
en termes de connaissances du mécanisme
à la fois en termes de régulation si il
en faut et si c'est possible et surtout
à mon avis en matière de d'experts cyber
qui seront capables d'assister à la fois
le législateur mais aussi
la DGFiP et l'ensemble des services qui
seront évidemment
impliqués face à la crise traversée par
le secteur des crypto monnaies les
appels à la régulation se font de plus
en plus pressants les États membres du
G20 ont ainsi affirmé dans une
déclaration commune vouloir rétablir un
cadre international pour réguler le
secteur à la manière de la finance
traditionnelle
voilà vous voyez s'afficher le mot
crypto monnaie vous êtes peut-être en
train de vous dire comme nombreux
d'entre nous mais qu'est-ce que c'est je
ne comprends pas donc on va commencer
par faire de la pédagogie ne vous
inquiétez pas avec mes invités claire
balvaboir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
experte indépendante en crypto monnaie
auteur de ce livre Bitcoin et crypto
monnaie facile publié chez First édition
Jean-Marc Daniel bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous économise professeur et
mérite à le SCP Business School et votre
livre est intitulé redécouvrir les
physiocrates publiées aux éditions Odile
Jacob jéromatisme bonsoir bienvenue à
vous professeur en économie en finance à
l'Université Paris Dauphine Mathieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés allez on commence par la pédagogie
comme promis premier chapitre vraiment
très pédago vous avez été obligé de
refaire l'explication que vous faites à
longueur de temps claire Balva on parle
de 5000 crypto monnaie mais en fait
c'est assez difficile d'avoir un chiffre
précis est-ce que ça veut dire que
n'importe qui peut potentiellement créer
sa crypto-monnaie déjà alors en théorie
oui en fait il faut quelques compétences
techniques effectivement
mais si vous créez une crypto monnaie ça
ne veut pas dire qu'elle vaudra quelque
chose et qu'elle sera utile à la société
donc quand on parle de 5000 crypto
monnaie en réalité ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il y a 5000 crypto monnaie qui valent
quelque chose qui sont utiles les plus
grandes crypto-monnaies je pense par
exemple la Bitcoin qui est la première
Bitcoin représente à peu près 40 % du
marché total des crypto-monnaies donc
est quand même très dominant sur ce
marché ensuite on a les terres qui est
la deuxième qui doit tourner entre 10 et
20% et ensuite effectivement on a une
ribambelle d'autres crypto monnaie une
crypto monnaie c'est quoi c'est une
monnaie qui exclusivement numérique donc
il y a pas de cash il y a pas de pièces
il y a pas de billets et c'est une
monnaie qui ne dépend pas d'une banque
centrale et donc qui est gérée par une
communauté d'individus d'entreprises de
gens qui sont passionnés un peu comme
dans le logiciel libre si vous
connaissez donc c'est pas il y a pas une
entreprise qui peut décider du jour au
lendemain on peut changer les missions
d'une crypto on peut spéculer ou acheter
des choses en crypto monnaie c'est ça
c'est les deux alors vous pouvez bien
sûr investir comme vous investiriez en
bourse par exemple pour diversifier
votre portefeuille
vous pouvez aussi vous en servir comme
moyen de paiement ou comme outil de
transfert d'argent à l'international
c'est utiliser par exemple par les
communautés d'expatriés quand ils
veulent envoyer de l'argent à l'étranger
avec moins avec moins de frais c'est
utilisé aussi par certaines populations
qui n'ont pas la chance comme nous
d'avoir une monnaie relativement stable
dans leur pays et donc pour qu'ils les
crypto monnaie sont une réserve de
valeur un peu plus intéressante donc les
usages sont divers mais c'est vrai qu'en
France c'est principalement une je
dirais une diversification d'épargne
plus qu'autre chose
très concrète si j'en veux j'en achète
tout alors vous en achetez sur ce qu'on
appelle des plateformes d'échange donc
qui sont des entreprises qui vont
centraliser la liquidité donc ils vont
avoir par exemple beaucoup d'euros et
beaucoup de Bitcoin admettons et donc
vous y allez vous vous inscrivez un peu
comme sur une banque en ligne donc on va
vous demander des informations sur votre
identité et puis après vous mettez votre
carte bancaire vous faites un virement
et puis la plateforme vous crédite deux
crypto monnaie où alors et c'est là la
grande particularité c'est que vous
pouvez décider de les laisser stocker
sur la plateforme mais vous pouvez aussi
décider des retirer dans un portefeuille
personnel de crypto monnaie ce que vous
ne pouvez pas réellement faire avec le
rose si vous le retirez c'est forcément
sous forme physique de cash et là avec
les crypto monnaie vous pouvez avoir un
portefeuille personnel numérique dont
vous êtes le seul détenteur alors on a
fait pas mal de pédagogie merci Mathieu
de poser aussi avec moi les questions de
béotien on est à peu près au même niveau
je pense l'un et l'autre en matière de
d'usage de crypto monnaie Jean-Marc
Daniel donc moi ce que je retiens c'est
que par définition une crypto-monnaie ne
dépend d'aucune institution financière
c'est aussi quelque chose qu'il faut
qu'il faut mettre en avant et ce qui
fait que ce n'est pas une monnaie c'est
pas une crypto monnaie d'ailleurs dans
le reportage on a dit crypto actif
crypto monnaie
la monnaie ça sert à acheter quelque
chose en France il y a un code monétaire
et financier qui dit que les seules
transactions que vous pouvez faire en
France sont en Euros l'article L11 du
post monétaire et financier dit vous
êtes obligé de fournir des euros et en
plus lorsque vous avez des euros sous
forme de cash le commerçant est obligé
de les accepter je sais pas si vous avez
suivi la Banque de France a appelé un
certain nombre de
grande distributeurs qui sont ouverts le
dimanche que ils ne pouvaient pas se
contenter d'accepter les cartes bleues
il devait mettre en place
systématiquement système qui accepte les
billets et les pièces donc légalement
tous ces systèmes là sont ne sont pas
des monnaies et ceux qui disent on peut
autant c'est illégal totalement
d'ailleurs les banques centrales le
systématiquement cherche à les
poursuivre et les banques centrales
disent en fait les gens qui utilisent la
crypto-monnaie c'est plutôt la
criminalité organisée en fait c'est pas
tout à fait vrai parce que la
criminalité organisée et on l'a dit sur
les pays où la monnaie est en train de
disparaître parce que la banque centrale
est le préserve sa monnaie mais il y a
des endroits où les gens ne font pas
confiance dans cette monnaie et les pays
qui ont essayé de se porter vers les
crypto monnaie pour se substituer à
cette monnaie qui est défaillante sont
en train de relancer parce que la
population elle ce qu'elle réclame c'est
des dollars c'est à dire que la monnaie
de référence mondiale quand tout va mal
c'est le dollar des États-Unis et
pourquoi c'est le dollar des États-Unis
pour trois raisons parce que avec le
dollar des États-Unis vous pouvez
acheter n'importe où n'importe quoi avec
le dollar des États-Unis vous avez un
appareil juridique derrière qui vous
protège et les règles de l'art des
États-Unis vous avez la première
économie mondiale derrière vous et donc
c'est ça qui est important alors pour
conclure ça peut être des crypto actifs
c'est-à-dire des objets de spéculation
mais c'est comme toujours dans toute
spéculation comme vous n'avez pas de
création de richesse derrière une
spéculation c'est un mécanisme de
transfert des richesses des uns vers les
autres et c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer il y a des gens qui ont
apporté de la richesse et puis en ce
moment ils sont en train de la perdre et
il y en a d'autres qui ont reçu cette
richesse à un moment donné et qui sont
en train de la conforter
jéromatis
l'avantage j'essaye de me placer en
usager des crypto monnaie l'avantage
pour un usager on part on reparlera
éventuellement de de d'escroquerie de
etc on verra on en fera un chapitre du
débat mais pour un usager qui est plein
de bonnes intentions qui dit tiens je
vais tester les crypto-monnaies c'est
quoi l'avantage il y a peut-être moins
de moins de taxes
sont pas les mêmes qu'on soit en France
ou sur le continent africain par exemple
il a été dit que certains pays africains
connaissent vous savez il y a un quart
des pays africains qui aujourd'hui
expérimentent une hyper une inflation à
deux voire trois chiffres donc quand on
est piégé par une inflation ou les prix
font plus que doubler d'une année sur
l'autre on a envie de se réfugier vers
des devises plus fortes ça peut être
l'euro ça peut être le dollar mais ne
sont pas toujours accessibles et les
crypto monnaie quelque part c'est un peu
une route secours qui est accessible à
ces populations alors je m'empresse tout
de même de préciser que c'est une roue
de secours qui seconde et se dégonfle
aux aléas en fonction des aléas du
marché parce que le cours de ces
crypto-monnaies varie en fonction de
l'offre et la demande et c'est parce que
il n'y a pas justement de banque
centrale pour réguler les niveaux que
cette route de secours se gonfle et se
dégonfle mais j'aimerais juste si vous
me le permettez en quelques secondes
faire un petit pas en arrière sur pour
bien expliquer aussi aux gens qui nous
écoutent l'enjeu qu'il y a derrière de
pédagogie ce n'est pas parce que jusqu'à
présent on a l'impression qu'on parle de
monnaie de spéculation etc et ça va
au-delà de ça parce que les
crypto-monnaies sont adossés à une
nouvelle technologie qui est la chaîne
de blocs et ça c'est une révolution qui
nous faut accueillir à bras ouverts
la blockchain c'est quoi comment ça
marche en chaîne de bloc c'est un
ministre distribué c'est une manière si
vous voulez d'organiser au sein des
ordinateurs la le stockage des données
de savoir qui peut y avoir accès ou
est-ce qu'elles sont logées comme on les
modifie qui est-ce qui vérifie qu'elles
sont corrompus ou non donc c'est un
algorithme qui finalement automatise
tout cela donc on a plus besoin
d'intermédiaires pour valider si je veux
parce que c'est compliqué ça permet
d'authentifier la transaction si
j'essaie d'être le plus basique possible
ça permet d'authentifier la transaction
ça permettez-moi de faire un palais avec
Internet et tout le monde va bien
comprendre internet à révolutionner il y
a deux trois décennies l'échange
d'information numérisée et bien la
chaîne de blocs aujourd'hui va
révolutionner l'échange non pas
d'information ça c'est internet mais de
valeur numérisée et donc alors la valeur
quand c'est une monnaie c'est une crypto
monnaie quand c'est un actif financier
comme m'a dit Jean-Marc c'est donc on
parle de crypto actif et cela va
fondamentalement transmuer un certain
nombre de corps de métiers qui sont qui
s'occupent de transférer cette valeur le
métier de la banque de l'assurance du
notariat les métiers de la comptabilité
et dans une moindre mesure du droit
parce que ça permet aux services
on aura besoin de remplacer alors on
remplace pas de A à Z mais on va amener
un petit peu plus d'ordinateur un petit
peu plus de technologie pour oui
remplacer certaines opérations bien sûr
Mathieu moi j'ai une autre question
basique puisqu'on est au début du débat
après on continue c'est qui crée qui
fabrique ces crypto monnaie parce que
Jean
clairs
crypto monnaie on parle pour la plus
grande qui Bitcoin c'est un anonyme qui
l'a créé donc on ne sait toujours pas
qui est le créateur de Bitcoin on
l'appelle Satoshi Nakamoto mais son
identité est toujours inconnu et c'est
d'ailleurs une des forces de Bitcoin
c'est d'avoir ce côté vraiment
décentralisé et cette indépendance
vis-à-vis de quelqu'un qui pourrait être
une sorte de figure tutélaire adulée etc
maintenant sur les autres crypto monnaie
bien vous avez parfois un ou plusieurs
personnages influant vous pouvez avoir
une entreprise vous pouvez avoir une
fondation donc théoriquement ça peut
être n'importe qui mais souvent les
équipes sont connues la philosophie qui
a derrière c'est quoi ces échappés
au système étatique aux banques centrale
c'est quoi le point de départ en fait le
point de départ alors encore une fois si
on remonte un peu dans le temps et qu'on
regarde le point de départ derrière
Bitcoin il y a une philosophie de je
dirais de protection de la vie privée
c'est notamment tout le mouvement safer
punk qui s'appelait à je dirais une
sorte de protection de des échanges qui
pouvaient avoir lieu sur Internet et
d'une méfiance envers les États ou les
institutions qui pouvaient espionner les
citoyens qui pouvaient les censurer etc
donc il y a effectivement derrière
Bitcoin un projet politique un projet
philosophique aussi et un projet
économique puisque c'est une monnaie qui
est en quantité limitée il y aura jamais
plus de 21 millions de Bitcoin
maintenant derrière d'autres crypto
monnaie on n'a pas forcément les mêmes
projets par exemple derrière la deuxième
ethereum il y a ce projet de
révolutionner la finance d'avoir des
applications financières qui vont plus
vite qui sont plus modernes et qui sont
programmables par tout un chacun alors
je vois qu'on essaie d'évaluer ce que
pèse les crypto monnaie aujourd'hui donc
on a cherché plusieurs sources à tourne
autour de 800 milliards de dollars il y
a 7 sources c'est quand une Market
cap.com qui dit 840 milliards de dollars
la capitalisation boursière globale de
ce marché des crypto monnaie
jean-marinier ça représente quoi en
comparaison de la fin de la
capitalisation mondiale c'est tout petit
ça c'est tout petit c'est tout petit
encore une fois c'est pas c'est pas de
la monnaie la masse monétaire mondiale
c'est c'est 100 fois ça c'est ça n'a
rien à voir avec la masse monétaire
mondiale et c'est d'autant plus petit en
tant que masse monétaire mondiale que
encore une fois c'est c'est illégal dans
la plupart des pays on a dit que ça a
l'air d'Afrique parce que la banque
centrale n'est pas en capacité de
répondre à sa mission traditionnelle et
donc effectivement comme on vient de le
dire les au départ il y avait une vision
philosophique qui consiste à dire on va
contourner ce monopole qui est la banque
centrale c'est c'est insupportable qui
est monopole assez souvent public pas
toujours public il y a des endroits et
des privés qui qui recule mais
en tant que tel jusqu'à présent la
population ne cherche pas fuir ni le
dollar ni l'euro ni le il y a plus une
à la fois une démarche philosophique et
puis l'idée que c'est un objet
effectivement de spéculation il y a pas
besoin quand vous allez chez votre
commerçant vous dites pas vous lui posez
pas la question est-ce que vous prenez
les Bitcoin vous avez des euros vous
donnez ça en euros et quand à la
technologie il est évident que le
système bancaire en tant que tel il est
en train de la digérer cette technologie
de la monnaie numérique elle existe déjà
votre compte courant il fonctionne de
façon numérique votre compte courant
c'est des transferts ça passe d'une
somme à l'autre et donc concrètement
c'est un enjeu qui est un enjeu qui sur
le plan strictement économique est assez
faible et qui est un enjeu sur le plan
juridique qui est assez fort et sur le
plan symbolique qui est un enjeu très
politique la dernière marque que je
ferais c'est qu'on accuse aussi le
Bitcoin vous posez la question qu'il est
créé sont des algorithmes programmes
avec un programme mathématique derrière
qui consiste à prendre des fonctions qui
vous attributs de façon aléatoire la
création de Bitcoin et donc le fantasme
c'est l'or c'est-à-dire l'or ça échappé
à la banque centrale alors ça échappé à
l'homme l'or c'était un don des dieux
alors c'est le soleil et donc il y a
toute une philosophie derrière tout ça
qui consiste à récupérer le vocabulaire
des orpailleurs le vocabulaire des
alchimistes et donc on mine
effectivement parce que on veut recréer
la fascination pour l'or mais ce n'est
pas de l'or et comme ce n'est pas de
l'or il y a un coût de production et
donc je signale qu'il y a quand même
maintenant tout un tasiologistes
radicaux qui accuse le Bitcoin de
provoquer effectivement des des drames
écologiques parce qu'il faut de
l'électricité et énormément
d'électricité pour faire vivre le
système alors qui utilise les
crypto-monnaies selon l'Association pour
le développement des actifs numériques
bon qui est forcément un peu engagé dans
le dans le mouvement 8% des Français 12%
des moins de 35 ans déjà investi dans
des crypto monnaie
géromatise qu'on ouvre quand même un
chapitre et le chapitre de des risques
que prennent ces et là on va rester en
France on viendra sur les exemples
étrangers un peu plus tard mais les
risques prennent ceux qui utilisent les
crypto monnaie déjà
alors on va employer un autre mot
compliqué pour le mot Darknet est-ce que
ces crypto-monnaies sont finalement
utilisés aussi ou prioritairement je ne
sais pas quelle est la réponse à la
question pour des achats
évidemment illégaux d'armes de drogue
etc etc tout ce qu'on peut trouver sur
le Darknet alors vous allez commencer
votre réponse par m'expliquer ce qu'est
le Darknet et ensuite répondre le Dark
web c'est un moteur de recherche enfin
ça ça si vous voulez quand vous allez
sur Google les moteurs de recherche
qu'on a l'habitude d'utiliser il y a des
sites légaux qui sont référencés les
sites illégaux n'ont pas le droit d'être
référencé sur nos moteurs de recherche
classiques et donc quand on baisse dans
l'illégalité on veut acheter de la
drogue des armes etc on va sur un espèce
de web parallèle que l'on appelle le
Dark web ou l'ensemble des sites
illégaux peuvent être visités et les
transactions se font bien sûr en crypto
monnaie pour faut pas que l'on puisse
retracer des transactions mais ça n'est
pas le gros c'est à dire que bien sûr on
peut aller en toute légalité acheter du
Bitcoin ou plein d'autres crypto monnaie
sur des sites standards maintenant oui
mais c'est quand même la monnaie d'être
trafiquants aussi c'est la monnaie un
petit un petit souci le social non quand
même oui tout à fait mais le Bitcoin
n'est pas du tout anonyme contrairement
à ce que on croit souvent parce qu'il
était présenté en tant que tel il y a
d'autres crypto monnaie qui sont
beaucoup plus qui ont été mises au point
spécialement pour les activités
mafieuses illégales pour lesquelles il
est encore plus dur de retracer
l'activité donc c'est ces crypto monnaie
si vous voulez j'aimerais quand même
peut-être dire un mot pourquoi il vous
avait dit une après de 5000 on sait pas
trop peut-être 3000 5000 et ça pourquoi
il y en a autant il faut comprendre qu'à
chaque crypto-monnaie il y a un projet
derrière c'est un peu comme si je vous
disais Air France demain a besoin
d'argent et plutôt que d'émettre des
actions ou plutôt que de lever des
obligations émet des miles et se met à
vendre des miles donc les utilisateurs
d'Air France vont pouvoir acheter des
miles qui pourront alors convertir dans
un voyage des bagages en plus etc et
bien derrière chaque projet crypto
monnaie c'est un petit peu ce qu'on nous
vend on nous vend le service d'une
entreprise et qui Prévent finalement ces
jetons d'utilisation donc voilà ça peut
être sur un secteur très spécifique très
spécifique et aussi pour ça qu'il y en a
plusieurs milliers aujourd'hui sur le
moi je continue par les trafic je dis
c'est la monnaie des trafics c'est
sûrement un peu caricatural mais c'est
une partie de la réalité non en réalité
bien sûr que certains trafiquants
utilisent les crypto monnaie mais en
réalité la plupart des trafiquants ils
utilisent quoi ils utilisent l'euro ou
parce que utiliser du cash c'est
beaucoup moins traçable utilisé du
Bitcoin et en plus on peut comme
Jean-Marc Daniel le disait acheter
beaucoup plus de choses en euros quand
Bitcoin ou que dans d'autres crypto
monnaie donc quand on regarde un peu les
statistiques parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
des entreprises qui se spécialisent dans
l'analyse de données sur ces fameuses
chaînes de blocs on voit que la
proportion de de transactions dédiée à
des choses illicites et dans constante
diminution on était dans les premières
années autour de 20 quasiment 30%
aujourd'hui on est à moins de 1% des
transactions qui sont pour des activités
illicites on est même tombé en dessous
des 0,1% donc en fait cette activité
elle est très marginale comparée à
l'ensemble des choses qui sont faites
avec des crypto-monnaies ça ne veut pas
dire qu'elle n'existe pas mais elle
existe aussi en réalité sur l'euro sur
le dollar sur la plupart des monnaies
alors j'ai reposer une question de
quelqu'un qui ne comprend pas j'ai placé
je dis n'importe quoi 1000 euros en
crypto monnaie et puis au bout de six
mois ça ils valent 2000 je veux
récupérer cet argent en refaire des
euros c'est possible bien sûr vous êtes
sur vous allez toujours sur cette
fameuse plateforme d'échange et puis
vous avez des boutons sur le trafic ça
peut redevenir des euros vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ils peuvent le faire
sauf que pour ça ils doivent encore une
fois s'inscrire sur cette plateforme
d'identité et donc si le régulateur
derrière mène une enquête et pas
forcément saisir ces différentes entités
et retrouver la trace des trafiquants
ce qu'on vient de dire effectivement je
crois que la monnaie des trafiquants ça
reste encore pendant très longtemps
c'était l'euro parce qu'il y avait des
billets de 500 euros ce qui permettait
de déplacer des sommes importantes avec
un volume relativement faible la Banque
centrale européenne ça n'est aperçue
donc on a arrêté ça et donc maintenant
ça reste le dollar l'avantage pour les
trafiquants de de l'existence c'est que
le lieu où on va retirer l'argent le
lieu physique peut être loin des
autorités judiciaires structurées
c'est-à-dire que les dollars il faut
quand même quelque part un moment donné
être aux États-Unis là alors bon il y en
a qui circulent la surface là vous
pouvez faire apparaître vos Bitcoin à la
surface de la planète n'importe où et
puisqu'il y a d'intéressant aussi c'est
que on parlait des actes militants il y
a un dossier qui a défrayé la chronique
qui était le dossier de de Seal quad qui
était un réseau qui vendait de la drogue
et tout ça et le bridge qui était le
l'organisateur de tout ça dans son
procès il a expliqué qu'en fait il a
expliqué les théories libertariennes
vont missiles et tout ça et donc il a
pas du tout expliquer qu'il était un
truand il a dit je suis pas un
sociopathe je suis pas un gangster je
suis un militant politique anarchiste
pour la liberté et donc il y a une
confusion derrière tout ça où on peut
dire en fait le il y a le crime organisé
il y a les gens qui ont une situation
philosophique de lutte systématique
contre ce monopole étatique et la banque
centrale et puis entre les deux il y a
tout un tas de gens qui sont assez
floues dans leurs intentions qui sont
objectivement des gangsters et qui
prétendent en réalité être des Robins
des Bois Mathieu juste une petite
question aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement utilisé comme valeur de
placement ou comme moyen de paiement les
crypto monnaie alors en France comme
valeur de placement principalement
beaucoup plus que comme moyen de
paiement encore une fois j'insiste
là-dessus je veux pas beaucoup c'est
interdit le code monétaire et financier
est clair et donc la bande de France
elle va s'abattre à un moment donné
quand elle le décidera sur les gens si
ça se généralise
pour le coup
je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord
parce qu'en réalité il y a un flou
là-dessus et il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises y compris des grandes
entreprises qui acceptent les paiements
en crypto monnaie et il y a des
entreprises qui se spécialisent dans
l'utilisation des crypto-monnaies comme
moyen de paiement donc après je voilà
pour le monopole pour avoir des
transactions plus sécurisées en fait on
recrée un truc purement spéculatif
spéculatif avec les mêmes défauts le
système financier classique
vous nous avez dit il y a une forme
d'approche révolutionnaire
c'est juste pour recréer un système
exactement le secteur effectivement se
réintermédient et on voit d'ailleurs des
dérives de la finance traditionnelle se
répliquaient dans le monde des
crypto-monnaies donc ça je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous
maintenant la France n'est pas forcément
représentative de l'usage des crypto au
niveau mondial il y a un Ukrainien
n'utilise pas les crypto pour la même
raison qu'un Français chacun y trouve
son intérêt alors sur le risque aussi le
l'Autorité des marchés financiers une
citation l'investissement en crypto
actif et risqué et de nombreux escrocs
opère sur internet alors sur le risque
forcément ce qui nous a donné envie dans
cette émission d'organiser ce débat
c'est cette faillite de FTX qui était
considéré comme la deuxième plus grande
plateforme d'échanges de monnaie
virtuelle au monde il y a eu plusieurs
milliers d'utilisateurs
ruinés
jéromatis c'est quoi ça ruine la
confiance c'est facile mais on enfin ça
fonctionne aussi là-dessus un système
comme comme celui-là comment vous
l'analysez peut-être la faillite et ses
conséquences surtout oui alors d'abord
je sousscris tout à fait bien sûr au
message de l'Autorité des marchés
financiers et je ne moi même des cours
de finances à mes étudiants à
l'université il faut savoir que eux la
nouvelle génération les étudiants ils
ont une vingtaine d'années beaucoup
d'entre eux ont déjà misé un petit peu
de leur épargne sur les crypto-monnaies
donc je le rappelle que c'est un peu
comme les gagnants du Loto on les
projecteurs se braquent sur le gagnant
mais on laisse dans l'ombre tous ceux
qui ont perdu et effectivement il y a
des gens qui enrichissent mais la
plupart des gens s'appauvrissent dans
ces histoires et rien que par exemple
sur le Bitcoin il faudrait pas qu'on
fasse toutes les missions sur le Bitcoin
parce que c'est une crypto-monnaie de
première génération aujourd'hui on en
est déjà des crypto-monnaies de 3e
génération le Bitcoin j'ai envie de dire
c'est déjà presque obsolète mais bien
que sur cette feuille oui alors juste un
mot sur le Bitcoin on estime qu'il y a
déjà 20 % qui ont été détournés c'est
dire ça veut dire quoi
qui ont été effectivement piratés 20%
des Bitcoin qui auraient été détournés
c'est-à-dire des gens qui pensaient
posséder du Bitcoin à un moment donné se
sont fait des trousser sur l'ordinateur
parce que donc là on est dans une
escroquerie pure totalement
oui enfin où on se sont fait confisquer
leur mot de passe par des pirates qui
ont récupéré des Bitcoin à leur place
bon en fait c'est vrai ça donne vraiment
pas envie d'y aller mais il faut être
averti il faut être averti en réalité la
plupart des Bitcoin ont été émis au tout
début de l'aventure de Bitcoin donc il y
avait beaucoup de Bitcoin émis et le
problème quand vous étiez dans Bitcoin
en 2009 2010-2011 c'est que vous
n'imaginiez pas que Bitcoin allait
valoir ses montants là 10 ans plus tard
et donc forcément il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui possédaient du Bitcoin en
2010 qui avait écrit leur mot de passe
sur un petit bout de papier par exemple
et puis qui l'ont égaré depuis
voler on a bien compris effectivement
mais donc c'est mon temps représente des
sommes de Bitcoin importantes mais qui à
l'époque ne valait pas grand chose la
faillite de FTX qui était une plateforme
d'échange donc on arrive on peut
échanger ces devises des euros des
dollars contre des crypto monnaie a fait
faillite parce que elle a été pris dans
des le marasme à la fois de piratage de
contes truqués elle n'avait pas toutes
les deux vis qu'elle prétendaient avoir
etc et en fait c'est ça ne se reproduit
ça se reproduira de manière certaine ça
n'est pas la première faillite d'une
plateforme d'échanges il en avait déjà
eu par le passé et ça n'est pas la
première ça n'est pas la dernière non
plus donc actuellement il y a à peu près
plus d'un millier de Français qui ont
été floués dans cette affaire qui se qui
essaient de monter une classe action ou
je ne sais quoi pour récupérer leurs
fonds mais c'est des investisseurs
l'action juridique de groupe donc ce
sont des épargnants qui ont perdu
économie et parce qu'ils ont été naïfs
ils ont fait au niveau mondial si on dit
un millier de français en France
qui ont été engloutis rendez-vous compte
il n'y avait même pas de contrat de
travail au sein de cette entreprise qui
était censé gérer des milliards de de
dollars c'est ce que j'allais vous poser
comme question Jean-Marc Daniel est-ce
que c'est révélateur finalement des
risques de de des plats alors je vais
pas faire d'amalgame mais des
plateformes en général à partir du
moment où on est un peu vous dit-il
légal ou en marge forcément il y a moins
d'opérations de contrôle les règles de
des institutions financières sont pas
forcément respectées etc etc oui tout à
fait d'autant plus que les institutions
financières ne se considèrent pas comme
en devoir de venir au secours des gens
qui ont été floués si une banque fait
faillite normalement vous avez une
garantie sur des pots et jusqu'à
concurrence d'une certaine somme les
autorités publiques vous rembourse ce
que vous avez perdu dans la faillite de
la banque là on les autorités
financières disent écoutez on sait même
pas que ces gens existent c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est ça nous est engagement
extérieur donc si vous perdez de
l'argent c'est c'est tant pis pour vous
on ne va pas se mêler si vous aviez joué
au casino exactement c'est comme un jeu
vous avez perdu tant pis pour vous on va
pas vous garantir quoi que ce soit et
donc dans cette affaire il y a des gens
qui ont perdu mais c'était monté très
très haut les gens qui ont vendu quand
c'était très très beau eux ils ont gagné
et puis à l'arrière en fait le fait
qu'il y a des mécanismes qui ont été de
création encore une fois ce qu'on a bien
dit c'est que au début on a créé
beaucoup l'idée c'est de rapprocher ça
de l'or et donc l'idée des fondateurs
c'est-à-dire on commence par exploiter
des mines d'or qui sont particulièrement
faciles à exploiter puis progressivement
on a trouvé tout l'or qui était
susceptible d'être trouvé donc on va
avoir trouvé tous les Bitcoin qui vont
et donc
ça avait comme conséquence de créer une
forme de rareté artificielle qui faisait
monter le cours donc il y a beaucoup de
gens qui se sont précipités sans
réfléchir à ce qu'il y avait
véritablement derrière alors on va se
poser la question maintenant avec Steve
Jourdain de la capacité d'encadrement
est-ce que c'est possible d'ailleurs de
de ces systèmes alors quand on
à s'attaquer à la question elle l'a fait
avec la loi pacte dans la loi pacte de
2019 le texte oblige notamment les
plateformes des crypto monnaie à
s'enregistrer auprès de l'AMF l'Autorité
des marchés financiers c'est un
mécanisme qui a d'ailleurs donné des
idées au niveau européen puisque cet été
les régulateurs se sont entendus sur
deux textes le TFR pour transfert au fin
de régulation et le Mika le market in
crypto à 16 concrètement l'obligation
faite aux plateformes de s'enregistrer
étendu à toute l'Europe et si elle ne le
font pas c'est plateformes seront
placées sur une liste noire par le
gendarme européen et puis les textes se
fixent aussi une obligation
d'information des consommateurs et la
constitution de fonds propres pour les
émetteurs de crypto monnaie l'objectif
de cette dernière mesure c'est d'éviter
que la faillite d'un opérateur ne
provoque façon domino une crise
financière de grande ampleur petite
précision Thomas pour terminer cette
régulation au niveau européen autrement
vigueur qu'en 2024 d'ici là beaucoup de
choses peuvent encore se passer si les
États-Unis tardent à bouger sur le sujet
j'espère que j'ai été complet on va voir
on va poser la question des experts
merci beaucoup si le Jourdain pour ces
pour ces précisions claire balval
encadrer les crypto-monnaies c'est
peut-être qu'en prononçant cette phrase
c'est une impossibilité par essence vu
ce que vous nous avez décrit de la
volonté de leur créateurs échapper
justement au système bancaire ou
financier traditionnel alors pas
forcément dans le sens où encadrer les
crypto-monnaies c'est très difficile
voire impossible puisque les crypto
monnaie ce sont des monnaies des actifs
des technologies donc ce qu'on encadre
ce ne sont pas les outils ce sont les
entreprises qui travaillent dans ce
secteur et donc typiquement quand on est
une plateforme d'échange aujourd'hui en
France on doit s'enregistrer auprès de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers donc
c'est d'ailleurs un conseil qu'on peut
donner aux auditeurs si jamais vous
souhaitez acheter de la crypto monnaie
il faut aller regarder quels sont les
plateformes enregistrées auprès de la MF
donc il y a des plateformes françaises
il y en a beaucoup il y en a une
vingtaine un peu plus qui effectivement
ont déposé un dossier auprès de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers
maintenant
étant enregistrement il repose surtout
sur des mesures de lutte anti
blanchiment c'est à dire que les
plateformes sont censées effectuer des
opérations de traçabilité des fonds mais
cette réglementation n'est pas aussi
lourde par exemple que celle du secteur
bancaire qui impose lui par exemple des
réserves de fonds propres des garanties
etc tout simplement parce que la crypto
c'est un secteur très jeune qui a une
dizaine d'années tout au plus et donc on
ne peut pas réguler une entreprise de 10
personnes comme on régule la BNP qui a
tout un service juridique donc forcément
cette réglementation elle se mette en
place petit à petit est-ce que
l'encadrement aurait évité la faillite
de FTX dont on parlait tout à l'heure
plus d'encadrement certainement mais le
législateur ici est une sur le fil du
rasoir parce que comme je disais d'un
côté il faut qu'il ouvre les bras pour
accueillir cette nouvelle technologie il
ne faut pas répéter l'erreur que nous
avions fait l'erreur européenne avec
internet ça n'est pas par hasard
qu'aujourd'hui aucun géant du web
n'est-européen c'est parce qu'il y avait
un excès réglementaire on accueillait
pas suffisamment ouvert internet donc
maintenant les géants sont du web sont
tous américains en chinois donc vous
dites accueillons la technologie
blockchain vous faites la différence
entre cette technologie et la
technologie blockchain et en même temps
et dictons des règles c'est strictes
pour encadrer et protéger l'utilisateur
protéger l'utilisateur on l'a dit
pourquoi pour le Pirata j'enverrai tout
ça mais aussi la société parce que il
est plus facile si un jour un employeur
vous paye en crypto monnaie il lui sera
largement plus facile de frauder les
cotisations sociales vous-même l'impôt
sur le revenu les transactions
commerciales on peut frauder la TVA
comme vous l'a dit Jean-Marc tout à
l'heure des crypto-monnaies en fait
c'est effectivement où on donne la
possibilité d'ouvrir des comptes
offshore partout des millions de cotes
content partout donc c'est très
difficile pour le législateur ou pour
les autorités fiscales de mettre la main
sur l'impôt et donc voilà il faut
encadrer de manière très stricte et
c'est ce film de rasoir dont je parlais
à la fois accueillir mais poser des
règles Jean-Marc Daniel il y a il y a
moins de recours c'est une la palissade
c'est une évidence voilà après après 35
minutes de débat mais il y a moins de
recours quand on investit en cryp dans
l'économie classique ah oui encore une
fois c'est un investissement c'est un
actif un actif avec d'ailleurs l'AMF sur
l'Autorité des marchés financiers c'est
pas on n'est pas sur le marché monétaire
de même on a parlé au niveau
international il y a effectivement des
travaux qui sont menés au niveau du FMI
le FMI enregistre les monnaies et les
monnaies qui sont enregistrées il y a
pas le Bitcoin dans les monnaies qui
sont enregistrées il y a l'Euro le franc
suisse
pourquoi parce que pour que ce soit une
monnaie il faut qu'il y ait un état
[Musique]
il y a une définition très précise avec
ce qu'on appelle le privilège des
missions c'est-à-dire il y a une
institution dans chaque pays dans tous
les pays du monde il y a une banque
centrale même les pays les plus
désorganisés comme la Somalie ou
l'Afghanistan il y a une banque centrale
et cette banque centrale a en face des
lignes de vie ce qui référencée et cette
banque centrale est supposée avoir ce
qu'on appelle le privilège des missions
c'est-à-dire le monopole des missions de
l'outil qui est accepté dans les
magasins et qui est accepté dans les
transactions et il a devoir physiquement
et juridiquement de poursuivre les gens
qui vont contre ce privilège des
missions alors forcément encore une fois
on l'a dit il y a des endroits où les
banques centrales sont incapables
d'assumer leur privilège des missions et
ce d'autant plus qu'il y a des endroits
où il y a des gens qui veulent porter
atteinte à ce prix en disant c'est un
monopole c'est de l'intrusion dans la
vie quotidienne c'est scandale et donc
effectivement une sorte de combat qui se
fait mais la banque centrale elle va pas
venir au secours des gens qui cherchent
à détruire son monopole par définition
elle va pas chercher à conforter un
système qui arrive comme vocation et qui
s'affiche comme tel de la détruire alors
on va faire un petit focus sur un
exemple étranger je vais vous donner la
parole parce que vous avez beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus on a un peu évoqué
mais ça peut être et donc on va aller en
Afghanistan là tout de suite je fais
signe à la Régie recours quand
l'économie d'un pays s'effondre écoutez
cet employé dans un bureau de change en
Afghanistan justement
on l'écoute
des talibans les transferts de crypto
monnaie vers et depuis l'étranger ont
augmenté de 80%. les gens l'utilisent
pour résoudre leurs problèmes de
transfert de devises
des devises étrangères de recevoir
l'argent envoyé ou d'envoyer l'argent
qu'ils veulent transférer c'est pour ça
qu'il se tourne vers les crypto monnaie
c'est plus pratique
est-ce qu'il y a des pays où une crypto
monnaie a quasiment remplacé la monnaie
nationale vous voyez ce que je veux dire
en volume je ne sais pas mais il y a
déjà au moins deux pays le Salvatore et
la Centrafrique qui donne un cours légal
au Bitcoin alors ça n'est pas pour de
bonnes raisons j'ai envie de le dire
j'ai envie de dire ça mais bon c'est
c'est il est possible en fait c'est les
individus composent avec ce qu'il aurait
donné si on dit c'est interdit de
l'utiliser il y a des pays qui l'ont
interdit le Maroc l'Algérie etc il y en
a d'autres qui le plébiscitent les
populations s'adapteront je ne suis pas
étonné avec ce que vient de nous dire
enfin ce dans ce témoignage de cette
personne afghane ça renvoie la bouée de
secours dont je parlais tout à l'heure
oui donc c'est quoi c'est quand le
système s'effondre c'est une ça devient
une bouée de secours c'est le Venezuela
par exemple le Bitcoin a énormément été
très populaire parce que avec
l'hyperinflation vénézuélienne et parce
que le dollar ne pouvait pas n'était pas
accessible à la population vénézuélienne
les gens se sont rués vers ce qu'ils
avaient à disposition il aurait été
préférable pour eux qu'ils aient accès à
d'autres monnaies fortes mais en
l'absence de cela ils se sont rués vers
ce qui met à leur vie dans ces deux pays
la Salvador et le Venezuela c'est que le
Bitcoin n'a été plus ou moins conforté
par les autorités légales parce qu'elles
étaient incapables d'imposer le respect
de leurs propres monnaie et l'idée de
passer par le dollar leur était
insupportable c'était le symbole c'était
politique
américain vous avez le dernier pays qui
vient de faire faillite c'est la Zambie
donc qui a fait faillite elle a elle a
refusé de payer sa dette et tout ça la
monnaie a disparu et donc il y a des
gens qui ont dit on va faire le Bitcoin
mais la population elle vit en rente
sud-africain l'élite vient de dollars et
il y a quelques individus qui vivent
dans le Bitcoin parce que on va pas se
soumettre à l'impérialisme américain
mais fondamentalement la population elle
c'est American dollars ou du rang sur
l'africaine parce que ça reste encore
pour la population c'est vieilles
monnaies ça reste encore quelque chose
d'encadrer de fiable et qui a fait ses
preuves mais Claire Balva on parle
d'inflation ou d'hyperinflation mais
quand on investit en Bitcoin ou dans les
autres crypto-monnaies il y a ça reste
aussi un souci c'est à dire que la
volatilité de de ces de ces monnaies
elle est elle est plus importante que
les autres moi je me souviens je sais
plus quel était la monnaie Elon Musk
Elon Musk qui parle d'une crypto-monnaie
c'était Dodge c'est ça Dutch coin alors
d'un seul coup ça prend je sais pas sans
200% et puis ensuite ça ça dévisse trois
mois plus tard parce que le Must
finalement on va pas l'utiliser enfin
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
c'est une volatilité Qui est à risque
quand même pour ceux qui l'utilise bien
sûr ce sont des actifs volatils il y a
pas il n'y a pas de doute là dessus
effectivement le prix dépend de l'offre
et de la demande donc si vous avez plus
d'acheteurs ça monte si vous avez plus
de vendeur ça descend donc ça c'est
assez clair maintenant quand vous dites
c'est volatile j'ai envie de dire ça
dépend par rapport à quoi c'est que oui
par rapport au dollar ou à l'euro par
exemple c'est globalement plus volatile
même si il y a certaines périodes on
pourrait trouver Bitcoin plus tard par
rapport au dollars que l'euro mais
globalement ça reste plus volatile
maintenant si vous comparez par rapport
à certaines monnaies où on en a pas on a
parlé du Venezuela de l'Amérique latine
on voit des pays qui sont en hyper
inflation et pour qui finalement sur une
certaine période de temps Bitcoin ou
d'autres crypto monnaie seront en fait
moins volatiles que leur monnaie
nationale donc tout dépend du
référentiel que vous avez si votre
référentiel c'est le rôle de l'art
effectivement vous allez trouver que les
crypto-monnaies sont plutôt volatiles
mais ceci étant dit cette volatilité
elle est principalement due à l'émission
monétaire qu'il y a sur Bitcoin qui crée
des chocs tous les quatre ans et comme
Bitcoin régie globalement le marché des
crypto-monnaies dans son ensemble ce
marché est principalement soumis encore
à l'émission monétaire de Bitcoin qui
est un actif jeune et en fait quand on
regarde avec le temps le Bitcoin devient
de moins en moins volatile même si je
comprends que ça puisse paraître
surprenant vu des graphiques qu'on a
mais aujourd'hui Bitcoin peut perdre 20%
dans une journée il ne peut plus être
divisé par deux ou par 3 dans une
journée comme ça pouvait être le cas il
y a 10 ans donc on a une volatilité qui
s'amoindrien en réalité une dernière
question il nous reste un peu moins de 3
minutes un dernier témoignage celui de
du patron de je sais pas comment on
prononce binance
principale plateforme d'échange de
crypto actif au monde c'était il était
présent à Paris entretien en marge de du
salon vivatech voilà ce qui nous dit sur
l'avenir
si vous regardez l'industrie dans 10 ans
dans 20 ans la technologie sera utilisée
par beaucoup plus de gens je crois que
dans 20 ans tout le monde utilisera la
technologie blockchain pour effectuer
des transactions de valeur auxquelles
ils ne penseront peut-être même pas
aujourd'hui je vous envoie un mail je ne
pense pas au protocole Internet je pense
pas internet je ne pense pas au câble ou
à des trucs comme ça je vous envoie
juste un message dans 20 ans quand
j'enverrai juste de l'argent ce sera
pareil
Jérôme Mathis les crypto monnaie feront
partie de notre quotidien les utilisa
sans y penser parce que oui tout à fait
alors je pense que le Bitcoin aura
disparu pour plein de raisons mais que
il aura été remplacé par des
crypto-monnaies personne ne peut sortir
sa boule de cristal pour savoir laquelle
prendra tout le marché personne n'y a 20
ans n'était capable de dire que Google
deviendrait le moteur de recherche de
référence à l'époque il y avait plein de
concurrents Altavista Yahoo etc qui ont
disparu et où Netflix mais et donc ça
veut dire que pour vous c'est crédible
dans nos transactions juste pour
spéculer pour acheter une baguette avec
son téléphone elle joue de la rue
aujourd'hui il nous sera impossible de
faire machine arrière on ne pourra plus
composer sans on composera avec mais
comme le dit très bien je pense le le
PDG de binance c'est que on le fera
d'une manière sans nécessairement avoir
été formé pour là on est à l'air tout à
fait innovation du début où c'est un
petit peu des geeks entre guillemets qui
savent comment ça fonctionne et qui s'y
intéresse et un jour ce sera popularisé
au point où on n'aura pas besoin de
connaître les mécanismes sous-jacents
pour les utiliser
mais ce sera des crypto dollars ce
serait géré par des banques
traditionnelles qui se sont appropriés
cette technologie et dans toute la
partie philosophique au mafieuse qui
consiste à dire on va détruire le
monopole de la Banque centrale et tout
ça ça va être évacuer assez vite en
revanche la technologie elle elle va
être appropriée par le système et ça
c'est une bonne chose allez-y termine et
tout à fait possible qu'effectivement il
dit des versions crypto du dollar ou de
l'euro ou de toutes les autres
oui mais c'est pas un crypto euro qui
est allé sur le département c'est plutôt
un neuro centralisé émis par la Banque
centrale mais il existe déjà aujourd'hui
par exemple des dollars sous forme de ce
qu'on appelle des stubble coin donc des
jetons stables qui circulent sur ces
fameuses chaînes de blocs donc ça ça
existe déjà effectivement donc la
finance traditionnelle s'approprie bien
sûr c'est ces technologies en revanche
alors moi je suis d'accord sur le fait
que dans 20 ans on utilisera à priori
tous ces technologies en revanche pour
moi Bitcoin serait probablement la
dernière crypto monnaie à disparaître
parce que Bitcoin est la plus résiliente
d'entre elles la plupart des jeunes
crypto monnaie aujourd'hui elles sont
très dépendantes de certains acteurs et
Bitcoin est la plus décentralisée donc
c'est bien la dernière que je vais à
disparaître dans 20 ans on pourra savoir
lequel de vous deux avez raison et on
posera plus les questions pédagogiques
on était hyper attentifs Mathieu je
pense j'espère que j'ai compris plein de
choses ah bah voilà c'était le défi
quand c'était lancé on a grâce à vous
compris beaucoup d'éléments sur cette ce
débat autour des crypto monnaie merci
encore je rappelle le titre de vos
livres Bitcoin et crypto monnaie facile
claire Balva publié aux éditions First
et Jean-Marc Daniel redécouvrir les
physiocrates livres publiés aux éditions
Odile Jacob belle soirée à vous votre
prochain rendez-vous sur notre antenne
rendez-vous politique c'est Arnaud
Robinet le maire de Reims président de
la Fédération hospitalière de France qui
sera l'invité Dorian Mancini demain
matin belle soirée